breaking news here at 6 30 Henderson
Police just releasing body cam footage
as part of a use of force investigation
and we first brought you the story last
night the coroner's office ruling
53-year-old Ronald winboard's death as a
homicide he died six days after he was
taken into custody at Sunrise Hospital
here's a look at some of that footage
now now first a warning some of the
images may be disturbing
switch again
this comes nearly two months after this
all happened on March 21st Henderson
Police say in winborne had been booked
on assault and resisting arrest charges
for threatening police with a knife he
then became medically unwell about six
days later and died at Sunrise Hospital
the coroner's office ruling windboard's
death was a homicide due to the use of
force during the initial arrest
Henderson Police will conduct an
internal investigation and will hold a
community briefing that will be at a
later date